I'm delivering some tacos to some hungry  fans today I gotta get it there before  practice ends let's go  [Music]  I hope I find the right field I got a  kids park over here a couple baseball  fields oh I see them putting in that  work over there  ready to win another state championship  oh you  know hey it's caught her back shoulder  oh yeah these girls know something out  here foreign  [Music]  I got some food for some chips  [Applause]  [Music]  you gonna run a route Mike's gonna play  outside left  [Applause]  you gotta watch the ball right  yeah all right get there here he comes  [Music]  my bad we gotta Get Hype  oh  y'all literally are the best though  [Music]